take my advice brother you should be out
there helping people like them other
fellas downtown really used to say the
same thing yeah she was right
awesome
hey
so Constanza been a-been day baby Allie
yeah baby a white
maybe a life
you're not down a few doors in the
projects and now you are on zero I'm
just getting started
you
hey youtubers is charlie sweet christmas
comes early so they dropped all this
Luke Cage footage let's break it down so
it's a whole bunch of footage but it's
really just meant to show you who these
characters are like who luke cage's who
the other characters are some of the
humor of the series like haha you know
isn't it funny to see a man with
bulletproof skin I'm getting really sick
of having to buy new clothes all the
time there's a whole bunch of misty
Knight who's kind of like luke cage's
love interest they I mean there are
references to his relationship with
Jessica Jones but the way that my
culture the actor that plays Luke Cage
described his series is that he has his
own stuff you know quote unquote own
stuff going on and that's basically
hip-hop Game of Thrones up in Harlem so
if you've never been to Harlem there's
this big picture of biggie painting on
the wall with a crown on his head in
that one of the big themes of the series
the showrunner said is everyone wants to
be the king you get this scene of Stokes
just beating the crap out of a character
with this painting behind them in
thematically personally it's very
important to the series and the
showrunner the showrunner himself was
one of the last people to interview
biggie before he died so if you don't
remember the East Coast West Coast of
90s hip-hop that was just a really
important that you know everyone wants
to be the king so thematically that
painting and that idea is very important
to the series so even though I'm kinda
you know tongue-in-cheek using Game of
Thrones to describe Luke Cage you will
see a lot of familiar things like
detective scarf here he plays misty
knights partner on the police force he's
kind of like a little finger character
someone who schemes and plots excuse
somewhat of a dirty cop but who exists
in that morally grey area that enables
him to work with the heroes in with the
villains and the funny thing that jeph
loeb said about the villains of the
series is we don't call them villains we
just call them the quote-unquote other
heroes of the series very you know very
tongue-in-cheek but the funny thing that
they also used to describe it is like
binging the 13 episodes is kind of like
listening to an album parlam itself is
very important to the story the music of
that area too so they called it kind of
like the wu-tang ification of the Marvel
Universe which i think is badass I mean
you've seen Luke Cage and Jessica Jones
you know what a badass he is so now
you're just gonna learn about all the
other [ __ ] that he has going on stuff
that caused him to have to bail at the
end of jessica jones and if it wasn't
clear i know like at the end of the
jessica jones series claire temple was
helping him out
she is also in the Luke Cage series but
the other cool thing to is that like at
the end of the teaser they also showed
off some iron fist footage if I can find
it i'll do a separate trailer video but
it was basically just a really quick
teaser like they posted a Punisher
teaser earlier this year after daredevil
season 3 came out like the Punisher will
return in his own series you know bump
um you know big gun shot fireworks go
off Jon Bernthal himself was at the
panel but he just kind of came for the
first little bit to see the big
defenders teaser say thank you and then
walk off there was they weren't hyping
up too much Punisher stuff but they did
confirm that they're working out a
Punisher series now the clip you see
black Mariah who's kind of like the
gerund hogarth of the series if you
remember the role that she played on
Jessica Jones she was you know very
morally gray character but wheel did a
lot of authority very antagonistic type
character someone who is a total badass
who wields authority through other
people and it all just looks dope as
hell so you guys can let me know like
what do you think about the footage what
did you think about luke cage during
jessica jones and now that we're getting
like the deep dive into his Harlem
universe wu-tang ification of the Marvel
Universe it just sounds so awesome if
you guys didn't know it's being released
September 30th and it's just like the
other Netflix series it'll all dump it
once 13 episodes then in the spring Iron
Fist will drop and then in the summer
defenders drops but if there any
questions of course I'm going to be
doing videos for just like I did for
Jessica Jones for daredevil season to
season 1 you get the idea but there is a
marvel giveaway that's going on boy you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video which is a
twin l or amazon gift card so just
remind you guys when I post my defenders
video next so that should post in a
couple hours so get height so why you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for my latest flash season 3 teaser
video and you can click here for all my
other comic con videos thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you